and now okay this will be about biasing
machine learning the old thing and I'm
gonna tell you what your algorithm yours
in particular is probably racist let's
start with Netflix last year they had
this pretty awesome controversy where
they showed creepy and racist ads to
people of color
basically what happened there are
algorithms earned some notion of
blackness and also learnt at black
people want some representation in
movies so they showed them ads with
black actors even though they aren't
really that much in the movies so kind
of misleading but what was really
amazing about this controversy was their
answer on this not surprising backlash
the answer was this one the last
sentence is important the only
information we use as a members viewing
history this is even worse than what
they actually did because they basically
remove all responsibility it's an
algorithm we didn't ask for admitting
is absolute [ __ ] right yeah of
course they learned some notion of
blackness and this isn't the response
you give when your algorithm is racist
let's look at another example language
right spoiler all human language is
biased so you don't have any possibility
of having unbiased language and you
always have to deal with that it's not
just racist language it's an orthography
lexicography krema
you have parts these are some just some
examples you have a symmetric remark
gender in English so an actor is
everyone acting but an actress is only a
woman acting you have a different
quantity of gendered inserts naming
conventions explicitly objectify women
like women often have names that our
objects are qualities this isn't in most
languages the case for men right when
you look at an application of language
language classification this was thought
of a soul
in the 90s what language is a given text
then it uses big news corpora
it's mostly unbiased text unbiased but
it's written a main dialect and it's
written by privileged writing staff
right which is here's code for white men
the problem is African American English
for example on Twitter is 20% less
likely to be classified so if you do
some market research you exclude 25% of
a minority and this just doesn't go the
problem with all of these is there are
no real easy solutions right to bias in
machine learning there's no quick fix
you have the most often this is the
solution companies use total avoidance
when black people were classified as
guerrillas on Google's image labeling
tech they just removed gorillas from the
post possibilities when Alexa tree
tested that you might want to kill your
first appearance they just room removed
those question from being able to be
answered does that make sense yeah
there's limited applicability solutions
that you with sexism don't work for
racism and vice versa
so even if you solve some kind of
discrimination it's still bigoted in
some other way
oftentimes they exploit some false
classification some proxy for what I
want actually to achieve and this isn't
a clean solution this isn't applicable
across across the whole spectrum there's
one easy quick fix for one particular
system always this is what they did by
the way for the image classification
thing they saw that black African
American English was often classified as
Spanish so they use that to reclassify
them and doesn't oftentimes it's there's
an introduction of even more priors and
meter parameters so for example when
every person standing in the kitchen is
a woman on image labeling they you have
to modify your in
put into the system to raise the
possibility to probability that the man
in the kitchen is actually a man yeah so
and when you deal with machine learning
where you already have so many priors
and meter parameters in introducing like
five six different parameters just to
deal with bias becomes quickly
unfeasible yeah so Latin talked so
already main takeaways just because
something uses machine learning doesn't
mean it's unbiased obviously all
language is implicitly prejudiced so
just don't you after the fact with it
training data doesn't make a difference
there were staff makes the difference it
really does you wouldn't classify people
of color as guerrillas if you had to
sing a person of color on your staff and
testing a system makes a difference a
lot of these things shouldn't have made
it to production Thanks
[Applause]